kabel zu kommen meine damen und herren
13 titel eingeblendet ist auch schon
hier der richtige rob schmidt da bleibt
und ihr seht doch schon zwischen uns
befindet sich ein glücksrad freunde wir
haben uns eigentlich gedacht dass wir
hälfte gut hälfte schlecht machen
irgendwie es noch mehr schlecht geworden
und 14 zähler die wir haben sind jetzt
zu zehn felder negativ wäre mir
verschiedene ekelhafte es sachen die
beispielsweise maden wir haben euch
schmecken hunde schokolade werden
verschiedene ekelhafte sachen die man
essen muss aber auf der anderen seite
haben doch ein paar sachen die positiv
sind weithin glas wasser oder da bekommt
man bei 5 50 euro schmecken aber gut ich
würde sagen dass wir beiden abwechselnd
drehen sowie in den anderen videos auf
die ich mit jude gemacht habe denn etwas
gezogen wurde bisher drei gekommen ist
wird durchgestrichen ja ob du das
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein hier etwas und marcello kennen ja
alle für ja entweder schon sauer dass
ich damit mal dran riechen
wir haben morgen zahl ist im menü ist
richtig geil nach wird auf jeden fall
durchgestrichen freunde das halt jetzt
mein geht da wenn ihre ich bin gespannt
was kommt keiner auf video gedreht was
bei heimerfolgs kanal auch schon video
gedreht was genau jetzt gerade auch
schon alles also das ist und in der
beschreibung verlinkt und dort haben wir
heuschrecken in einem auflauf gegessen
die fand ich schon hart ekelhaft war
jetzt sich ist wie ist bei dir am besten
eindruck rhein-main verkehr hat davon
ist die branche nicht lecker die sind
auch nicht länger ich dachte ja geht
wenn du kotzen muss dann geh auf
magister rede mal nicht ich dachte dass
die forscher das ist falsch was ist das
nur wenige minuten später
ich hab runtergeschluckt aber das pech
hat sich kurz im moment gedacht haben so
nachgedacht habe ob ich war gerade auf
dem kopf von der heuschrecke boah da war
noch alles drin
egal war glaubt machen
du hast dass sie locker verstellt oder
so mit drin lassen
der geschmack ist auch richtig tief fest
fan seite kann ich hier eigentlich
altern hier sitzt am flügel tten in den
abstieg ich hoffe es ist irgendwas
tomatensoße alte haye ist es da der
schein er sowieso ganz bestimmt nie
wieder ein video mit ihr auf ich könnte
ja auch etwas wodka zu kippen dann hätte
alles okay die sache da schmeckt gut in
kombination mit der heuschrecke aber
dann kann man weiter mein magen dreht
sich halt um hier gerade die ganze zeit
also bisher hatte ich wirklich nur
negative sachen und wird nur positive
sachen deswegen kommt
jetzt
alter ist absolut logisch aber schon
groß dass mit dem ersten bild vom die
selbst mit anklängen
ich habe keinen platz wo ich sind
ungewiss
ich ging zu dem upload und dagegen
gehalten hab runter damit herrscht hier
drin ist er schmeckt nicht glaubt
immerhin ist es ja auch nur normales da
ist es passiert haben auch schon
aufgehört das so lieber in deutschland
trinken kann es halt irgendwie wenn man
anderen ländern aus den leitungen zahlen
oder wie ich glaube trotzdem dass es
nicht das beste für den magen ist aber
geschmacks technik geworden
ihr ziel war es natürlich auch weg
freunde wir haben es auch so wie bei den
letzten videos hier auch das wird jetzt
etwas gezogen wie etwa zwischen hatten
ja ich dachte erst ich muss mit den
daten sparte noch mal drehen ins raster
ich ziehe nur negative sachen naja ok da
verstehen was ich meine instagram
stallman
du musst öffentlich zugeben dass die
braun das beste team auf youtube
deutschland ist alt und verlinkt mich
dann endlich das in meiner story
aufteilen dann sieht dass simon leute
aber damit jetzt bist du dran die sache
ist dass mittlerweile echt eine menge
positiv dass jetzt doch nicht weiß ein
bisschen vorrunde schon korrekt
liegestütze geht's nicht so schlimm ich
weg doch auch jetzt nur scheiß sachen
die sehr wie gestützt so das was auch am
wenigsten schlimmes denken sehen so viel
wie du kannst 100 jahre lang keine werde
man vielleicht hier so heuschrecken 13
16 10 310 24
hier wird nur größer zwischenstand wir
haben noch nachts flatscher warten dann
aber auch eine massage man bekommt vom
anderen wir haben noch wunde schoko was
negative dinge es auch negativ mehr noch
den joker und 50 euro
so wie ich mich kenne sich jetzt machen
wo ich führe das höhere alter entspannt
so könnt ihr mal video
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das ist der held umfasst neben nie
wieder mit dir ein video und das ist ja
echt krank ich und ich bin dir wieder
ich liebe es mit dir zu drehen das waren
so viel spaß weil ich doch schon einige
wetten gewonnen
für einige zeit mit ankündigung ist
jetzt warten
[Musik]
das mag ich nicht so schnell ich kann
jetzt kopf war ich neben ihm da wird
irgendwann auch mal ein nein bekommen
gerade 50 euro von mir mein erstes mal
maden essen besser als heuschrecken oder
ich finde die echtheit nicht so schlimm
kann ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen wenn
man nicht weiß dass die smarten sind
dann denkt man ist ein ganz normal so
nüssel wtv ich weiß jetzt dass hier
hinten links heuschreck oder marketing
ja man hat mir durch
danke schön weiß was das heißt dass du
kannst nichts negatives
der joker umkreis ich mal heißt es denn
jetzt hast und das heißt wiederum das
rock band jetzt erst mal eine sache
kommen kann er die einfach weg so kann
sage ich mal
[Musik]
ich habe mir gerade gesagt wir sollen
100 schokolade mit drei nehmen und ich
habe das einmal probiert und das war
echt nicht nein danke
ich weiß nicht sehen ihr müsst euch
merken aber ich verstehe nicht was daran
schokolade sein soll außer dass sie
irgendwo nach schokolade aussieht
[Musik]
schokolade als er wie so ein stück
butter was man essen würde oder herunter
hat er überhaupt nichts mit schokolade
und die nein
selbst der ist das nicht so locker
also ich aktivem einen jogger sind das
war das wirklich am wenigsten kann es
jederzeit singen wird einfach durch
gestrichen
also dann werden halt gewesen sowie jule
so letztes mal
jetzt ist quasi fette kopf bekommen und
hätte ist laut bei irgendeinem es nicht
katja oder bibi zeugen oder so mitsingen
müssen aber gut wenn ein job annimmt
okay dann ist der job geht allerdings
auch weg das heißt das letzte was übrig
ist für mich ist der nacken klatsche und
so haben wir ein schönes ende für sie
zumal es hat so höhen und tiefen und ein
sauberes bett ihr hat es nur relativ
[Musik]
der war so richtig will auch ein
glücksrad ist noch zum friseur
ich kann den nicht geben an der stelle
wird das sollte ich mich jetzt werden
beide damen und herren wenn es durch
gefallen hat das gerne mal einen like da
ich musste jetzt eigentlich primär
schlechte sachen machen ja und du hast
50 euro bekommen ja war auf jeden fall
sehr interessant mit dir muss ganz
ehrlich sagen
auch vox kanal haben wir auch ein video
gemacht wo wir unter anderem mit
heuschrecken gekocht haben und
beispielsweise auch lauf gemacht haben
oder mit tintenfisch haben wir auch noch
was gemacht also schauen auf jeden fall
dort auch vorbei wollt ihr dass ich
eventuell nochmal eine glücksrad stellen
schokolade vielleicht auch mit einem
anderen gast vielleicht mit anderen
aufgaben schreibt gerne in die
kommentare und jetzt ist es wieder
vorbei
[Musik]
die